-Our next guest hosts
"A Little Late with Lilly Singh"
at 1:35 a.m. right after
this show here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Lilly Singh!
How are you, Lilly?
-Good! How are you?
Thanks for having me.
-Oh, my God.
I'm so happy to have you.
You were last here the night
of your Season 1 premiere.
You're now in Season 2.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And as a fellow host,
I have to ask
how are you finding
interviewing people over Zoom?
-I hate it.
-Yeah.
-I really hate it. [ Laughs
No, you know what?
There's pros and cons.
I'll be honest.
When I first jumped into this,
I was concerned
about the Zoom element.
I was like, "Oh, I won't be able
to pick up on
people's body language.
I won't be able
to feel their energy."
There's pros and cons.
I think a pro is that
for the first time,
you can talk to anyone
anywhere in the world.
So, you know, I just had
a guest that was in Kenya,
and that was super cool.
I was like, "Okay, that's cool."
But, I mean, the tech side
of things is just --
We're shooting in a house.
The wi-fi was an issue
for the first week.
I also can't see the bottom --
I'm wearing such a cool outfit
You can see half of it.
It's, like, not doing justic
to the whole outfit.
-So, a lot of us who have thes
late night shows had this studio
and then we went to our homes,
and then we felt very luck
to get back in the studio.
You had a different progression.
You were in a studio
for Season 1,
and now you are in
a much more comfortable setup.
What led to this --
There you go.
That's the actual pillow.
Oh, my God.
We got the pillow on the show.
So, talk about
the decision you made
to change the way
you do your show in Season 2
-Yeah, you know, when I di
Season 1 in the studio,
I did it admittedly
because I thought,
"Okay, I want to be different,
but also, this is the late night
I'm used to," you know?
You have a beautiful studio.
So does Jimmy.
And I wanted to be part
of that cool kids club.
But I had to be honest wit
myself at the end of Season 1.
It's just not very me.
You know, I think
I'm the type of person
that likes to walk around
a house, be a little more DIY.
I'm not as fabulous as you guys,
is honestly what it is.
It's like I'm not
as professional
to sit at the desk and stuff
So I thought, everyone's tryin
to get into a studio,
but I want to get into a house
where, more importantly,
I can control the thermostat
because I know you and your crew
are freezing right now
in that studio, Seth.
For me, we're warm.
-It is the dirtiest secret
about late night
is how cold it is
in our studios.
Thank you for
letting the world know.
-Exactly. So, the house
just feels a little more m
and a little more authentic.
-That's great.
And you had a witch.
I hope that's
the acceptable term.
-A good witch, yes.
-She came to see --
because you're shooting
in a home
that is not your own --
to see if the house was haunted.
How did you find her,
and more importantly,
what did she find in the house
-Haunted.
-Really?
-Haunted. So haunted. Yeah
She came --
Well, here's the thing.
I told my crew, I was like -
I'm really big on energy, Seth
You know, I'm really about
new space --
I want to feel good
in the energy,
make sure there's a lot of lov
and light in it.
So I wasn't really
expecting them
to bring a full-fledged witch.
You know, I was like --
You know how it is, Seth.
I was like, "Okay, I'm going
to prep for this segment.
I'll go.
I'll act a little spooked.
You know, it's a witch."
But then I walked outside and...
Seth, she was a witch.
Like, I don't know --
She was a full witch
with a broom, with potions
with everything.
And so she went
through the house with me,
and she said, "Yeah, you know,
I picked up on some energy
especially around the pool."
And now, Seth, I want you --
Okay, we're walking to the pool.
And you know me.
I'm making good TV.
I'm like, "Okay,
let's walk to the pool."
We go to the pool.
Both of the cameras
stop working.
Like both of -- Yeah.
At this point, obviously,
I'm crying, obvs, right.
And so I'm like, "Hmm."
Then she has these little sticks
that communicate
with spirits basically,
and she says, "Are you messing
with the cameras?"
And it answers yes.
And at this point, I'm like,
"Hmm! This is much more than
just a good produced segment
There's something else
going on here."
And then she concludes
by telling me,
"And, Lilly, the spirits
can come home with you."
-Really?
-Yes! And, Seth, I kid you not
Two days prior to this,
I saw two footsteps
that are not my own --
They're very big footsteps -
in my house,
leaving from a door
that are unexplained.
-This is -- This is shocking
and one of the reasons
why I refuse to have a witch
in this studio.
-I didn't sign up
for this part of the job.
-These are answers
I don't want to --
-I signed up for interviewin
guests, for telling jokes.
I didn't sign up for this,
for spirits coming to my house
-You also had a woman on
recently who believes --
is of the belief
that she had relations,
physical relations,
with an alien.
-Yes.
-How was that conversation
-It was good. You know, what I
want to do on Season 2 is --
And I'm sure you know this -
Talking to celebrities is fun.
They're super fun.
They're glitz. They're glamour
But I have a really
big desire to talk
to people who don't always get
the chance to be on late night
that have really
exciting stories
or are doing great things.
And this lady was no exception
She had a viral TikTok
where she told the story about
how she hooked up with an alien.
And obviously after watching
this one-minute TikTok,
I'm like, I have so many
follow-up questions
about this alien intercourse
So I brought her in,
and she told me the entire story
about how, you know,
she met the person on Hinge.
He got to her house
way too quickly
based on where he said
he was coming from.
He acted really weird.
His skin was weird.
Then she had no memory
of the interaction for --
It was, like, really
interesting and weird.
I believe her, I just want
to go on record and say.
I feel like anyone who publicl
says they don't believe he
is trying to get abducted, and
I'm not trying to get abducted
-Gotcha. I am both
not trying to get abducted
and I don't believe her.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, good luck, Seth!
You made your bed.
-We will see how it goes.
But it's true, because
we both talk to celebritie
all the time, and not one
celebrity on my show
has ever made it with an alien
-Exactly, exactly.
-So that speaks to how
sometimes you have to go -
-And even if they did,
their publicists would never
let them give details.
-You're right. If it happened,
they'd be like,
"They don't want
to talk about the alien."
-Exactly,
"No questions about the alien.
Yeah, talk about their book.
-You shot -- Back when
you were getting started,
you shot in your parents' house.
Are there any differences
between shooting
in this rental house/studi
than it was versus
shooting at home?
-Yeah, I mean, I am still
100% Indian in the core,
so I have a lot
of cultural things
that are really a problem
for me every day.
Like, for example, Seth,
there's a white carpet under me.
I'm wearing shoes. Look at this.
-Wow.
-They're making me wear shoe
on this white carpet
and shoes everywhere
in the house,
and that would never happe
if I was at my parents' house.
Also, I'm very loud.
Everyone in this neighborhoo
is very loud.
So when we found this house,
we were like, okay,
it's in a quiet neighborhood
Perfect.
Day 1 shooting, Seth,
we discovered
the neighbor
is actually a drummer
who practices
about eight hours a day.
So underneath all of my --
-And he died five years ago.
-Yeah, literally.
It's -- It's ridi--
Under every episode,
there's drumming.
So it's part of our show now
It is what it is.
-There you go.
It's a house band.
Hey, congratulations
on Season 2.
Thank you so much
for being here,
and I hope everybody enjoy
watching you tonight.
Thanks, Lilly.
-Seth, thanks for being
so supportive all the time
as well. Appreciate it.
-My pleasure, of course.
"A Little Late with Lilly Singh"
airs at 1:35 a.m. here on NBC.